[Música]
sólo dos a la mañana y media ya pidieron
comida por supuesto está en sala de
urgencias y hay que comer obviamente se
llama urgencias metabólicas
y tienen 13 pacientes a su cargo de
estos 13 pacientes 2 se van a rebelarse
a sus casas felices no pasa nada
un paciente tal vez se tengan que quedar
15 después a ver si le puedo un poquito
de paracetamol mejoralitos y le vaya
bien
y de repente todo tranquilo
escuchan cómo suena el teléfono rojo de
la central de enfermería
y ese momento se quedan paralizados
porque porque su primera guardia solos
tienen años estudiando tienen muchas
desveladas tienen noches y noches en la
biblioteca y en el hospital y demás y
todos esos años desvelos sacrificar
cosas se resumen en esta llamada
el tiempo va cambiando dependiendo del
contexto con el que tú
por ejemplo si tú
estás esperando una llamada que pueda
cambiar tu vida y la vida de alguien es
esa llamada de dos minutos parece una
llamada de 30 minutos
es desesperante como ves la enfermera
toma el teléfono contesta y sabe
que esa llamada significa algo malo pues
es una ambulancia puede ser algo
bastante sencillo un niño llorando
deshidratado
algún problema sencillo de resolver la
más espantosa llamó la ambulancia pero
lo más probable es que venga con un
problema bastante serio
entonces te quedas completamente
paralizado
lo siguiente que viene a tu mente es que
hago como proceder qué es lo que yo debo
de realizar en mi primer guardia en tu
sala de urgencias hay gente con
muchísima más experiencia que tú
realizando este viendo este tipo de
pacientes graves pacientes que se pueden
complicar en cualquier segundo parpadea
si el paciente ya se puso mal otra vez
sin embargo
la decisión que va a valer esa noche es
la tuya tenemos derecho a equivocarnos
tenemos derecho a decir y creo que no
era por este camino
vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa
ves como va entrando tu paciente ves
como se abre la puerta a los 15 minutos
que llegaba la ambulancia se condicionen
dos minutos cambio una vez más en el
tiempo esas tres horas de llamada ahora
se cometieron en dos minutos que llegó
la ambulancia
el paciente cruza la sala como empieza a
gritar como estaba manoteando como está
combativo si quiere arrancar todas las
soluciones tú recuerdas la llamada y que
tiquete dijo la enfermera viene un
paciente de 25 años que fue atropellado
en la vía pública o en la autopista
méxico-puebla fue salió proyectado 5
metros una charco de sangre 30
centímetros porque finalmente signos
claros de fractura craneal de luxación
de hombro después bastante sangre en
cuanto habéis cruzar a los pacientes lo
ponemos que te das cuenta es
para el paciente dónde está digo si
viene gritando si viene manoteando pero
es ahora que está pasando
y lo más importante aún ha permitido
algo
y la siguiente pregunta que viene a tu
cabeza es ahora qué hago qué sigue
me di cuenta en años de estudiar
medicina y sigo estudiando medicina
porque no voy a dejar de estudiar en
muchísimo tiempo
es que necesitas tres aspectos
fundamentales pues para poder realizar
cualquier trabajo la primera parte es la
anatomía fisiología en mi área que es la
base teórica de todos la anatomía de
saber cómo está conformado el cuerpo
humano y la fisiología de saber cómo
funciona el cuerpo humano no podemos
siquiera pensar en diagnosticar algo sin
saber cómo funcionan normalmente
representado a cualquier otra carrera
trabajos en la parte teórica que es
básica y elemental para poder hacer lo
que sea aunque no sé experta en esa área
lo segundo es el sentido común que es el
sentido común
se puede aumentar el sentido común
hay muchísimas definiciones y qué
flojera leerlas todas vámonos con la más
simple hacer las cosas de la manera más
lógica posible de la forma más racional
posible y la forma más sencilla posible
la distancia más corta entre dos puntos
es una línea recta a veces hay que
juzgarle un poco pero si la mantenemos
lo más recta posible y es lo más lógico
pues adelante es lo más fácil sencillo y
casi siempre efectivo y esto nos lleva
al tercer punto que a mi criterio es la
más importante para desenvolverse en
cualquier área e incluso para vivir el
día a día tomar decisiones
y viene la pregunta por qué es tan fácil
quedarse paralizado recordemos que
tenemos seis años estudiando medicina lo
que ustedes gusten y cuando llega un
problema del cual ya se ha estudiado
mucho has leído mucho y se supone que
sabes mucho
te quedas paralizado con tan solo una
llamada de dos minutos porque si tienes
la teoría tiene sentido común
y sin embargo te quedas completamente en
blanco y te quieres to desmayar en ese
momento
porque es tan sencillo el no hacer nada
porque es lo más fácil por supuesto le
pongo no le pongo no mejoro agonal y que
venga el médico de la noche
vamos a hacer un poco fríos y vamos a
aterrizar nuestro contexto al día hay
mil accidentes en el país esto es un
reporte del inegi de estos mil
accidentes más de la mitad un 60% va a
termina en sala de urgencias donde puede
ser un simple golpe ras por un punto de
sutura
pero uno de cada dos de esos pacientes
creativamente no graves van a terminar
estado bastante graves
como es el caso del paciente que estamos
viendo
volvamos a nuestro paciente es como la
camilla se va llenando de santos
paramédicos la pasan de la camilla de la
ambulancia la camilla rígida y
automáticamente ves como la cabeza
brotando sangre y dices por qué de tanta
sangre dios
es una fractura bastante evidente y es y
será malo huesos rotos pues sí qué tan
malo es no lo sé pero se ve malo se ve
muy muy muy malo que puede pasar ahora
lo siguiente que tú ves investiga pues
palpa todo el cuerpo hace es el abc de
tan sencillo como las cinco primeras
letras a b c d a diaria y control
cervical donde tú tienes que ver que el
paciente pues pueda respirar bien que el
paciente tenga permeables el aire puede
entrar de la nariz ha de hacer los
pulmones
tú ves si eso es está bien puede pasar
el aire pasas a la vez que es el
paciente pueda ventilar el solo una cosa
es que el aire tenga por donde pasa y
otra cosa es que el cuerpo haga que ese
aire pase automáticamente cuando tú ves
el tórax ves que no se expande igual
sino de un lado si el otro no y ahí es
la primera decisión importante casa
tomar ese día ese momento que hago si el
pulmón está ponchado
y sentido común que me dice pues tengo
que des poncharlo como una aguja palpó
pico y se escucha un
tan sencillo como eso y mi corazón
vuelve a latir tranquilo porque el
paciente va a respirar otra vez
vámonos con la clase circulación y
control de hemorragias vemos cuánta
sangre está perdiendo el paciente y
vámonos a la primera parte de teoría si
el cuerpo tiene de 5 a 6 litros de
sangre mi paciente perdió 300 de él
el charco más una fractura de hombro que
es medio litro más otros dos litros del
fémur más la cantidad de litro que tiene
algo clavado en la panza más lo que no
sé que tiene sangrado interno vamos más
de tres litros entonces el paciente
perdió más de la mitad de su sangre la
sangre es un líquido como re pongo esa
manera rápida
si le falta agua pues le poco agua
canaliza los 22 días para salir a chorro
abre las dos para sale muchísima
cantidad de agua y por lo menos ese
paciente por esos 10 minutos va a estar
vivo entonces estamos regalando 10
minutos extras para que ese paciente
pueda seguir adelante seguimos
investigando y en la parte de la de que
es cuando revisamos el estado de
conciencia bien la parte de la e
desconectamos completo a nuestro
paciente
en tan solo
15 minutos hemos hecho acciones que nos
han tomado años conocimientos y los
hemos recibido ahora siguiendo tres
leyes básicas
teoría sentido común y derivamos en
tomar decisiones que es lo más
importante no nos quedamos parados esto
nos lleva a entender que las decisiones
son simples decisiones no hay buenas ni
malas porque porque depende mucho el
contexto del en el cual tú tomes esa
decisión y en algún momento tú te parece
una muy buena idea tomar esa decisión
por ejemplo
hay un estudio del doctor dif y es
publicado en la unam que no dice cuáles
son las variables relacionadas al mayor
riesgo de errores médicos porque los
médicos también son humanos y también
tomamos muy malas decisiones sin embargo
en el contexto de ese momento aparece
una buena idea viéndolo al resolutivo no
era tan buena idea
vemos que el primer la primera causa
relacionada a un mayor riesgo médico es
la inexperiencia de los médicos o el
personal es decir médicos jóvenes
y recordemos que nuestro paciente era
nuestra primera guardia solos si tuvimos
muchísimas guardias en internado con el
escrito y que tú puedes tomar ciertas
decisiones pero al final tu escrito al
final al final tu hoja y listo las
consolida de él o se hace algo mal te lo
corregía aquí estás solo acá te
equivocas y no hay quien se va a decidir
estás bien estás mal como es entonces
que los médicos jóvenes vamos a tomar
decisiones
nuestro mapa básico teoría sentido común
deriva en tomar decisiones
también hay pacientes en los extremos de
la vida que son mucho más complicados
son diferentes etcétera
a atención en urgencias esa es otra
variable de errores médicos porque por
el tiempo cuando empezamos dijimos que
los 15 minutos pueden durar 2 minutos o
parece tres horas depende del contexto
si ustedes ven un paciente que viene con
un sangrado del dedo pues son 15 minutos
sin un paciente con un sangrado que es
nada más levantar la gasa y se vacía
medio corazón en el suelo en un charco
pues ahí sí ya no son 500 esos se te van
pero rapidísimo
entonces
cómo es que nosotros podamos hacer para
que nuestras decisiones estén basadas en
algo que nos dé más confianza de
nosotros mismos
en medicina por ejemplo
hay muchos protocolos que se nos enseñan
para poder tomar estas decisiones que es
un protocolo una definición bastante
buena del colegio americano de cirujanos
es un conjunto de
es un conjunto
de acciones ordenadas que tú vas a
realizar para no olvidarte lo importante
abc de tan sencillo como eso y en 15
minutos hablamos la vida de alguien con
saber te las 5 primeras letras es un
protocolo hecho justamente para que no
olvidemos factores y aspectos
importantes por ejemplo si estamos
hablando de sistemas y un banco pues la
talla que ustedes gusten en el país
sufre una caída cuánto tiempo tiene un
técnico o un profesional en sistemas
para restablecer esa línea o sea nos
vamos a pensar qué pasaría si un banco
pierde la la red por tan sólo cinco
minutos cuantos hackeos puede haber en
las cuentas de los clientes qué puede
pasar y cómo fue repercutir en ese banco
que para ser es un banco cierra por eso
estás hablando de una
de algo catastrófico desde cierto punto
de vista de los negocios y demás que
hace un ingeniero en sistemas pues
también tiene su serie de pasos para
poder investigar dónde está el problema
primero tiene que ver la conexión entre
los dos routers tiene que ver
preguntarle a la computadora
entre comillas qué es lo que está
pasando entonces en nuestra vida los
protocolos están hechos para poder
solucionarlos la existencia para darnos
confianza en las decisiones por supuesto
que las decisiones jamás van a ser
automáticas los protocolos no
automatizan las cosas simplemente nos
ordenan los pensamientos para que así
sea más fácil
tomar decisiones en sus trabajos en sus
profesiones qué protocolos tienen se han
puesto a puede pensar en la parte más
interesante y rica de todo esto es que
protocolos han creado ustedes
se considera una persona metódica si una
persona metódica hace todo de una manera
ordenada para no olvidarse eso serio
protocolo por definición cuantos
protocolos tienen ustedes para poder
solucionar sus propios problemas
cuántos protocolos tienen ustedes para
tanto el trabajo para el área
profesional porque no creamos uno porque
no creamos una forma ordenada de hacer
las cosas donde no se nos olvida nada
donde sencillamente
tenemos una forma metódica de llegó pasa
esto hago el otro y así vas tomando
decisiones y lo más importante es que no
se quedan parados
una decisión la peor de todas es no
hacer nada porque eso siempre va a
terminar mal casi siempre va a terminar
muy mal juego a pago ve a goce una
jornada cualquiera lastre de batería una
repercusión una consecuencia puede ser
buena o mala tiene que tener un plan
alternativo para poder contrastar si es
que es mala o si es buena con el
protocolo es mucho más fácil muchísimo
más fácil porque no pensamos todo
nosotros en crear nuestros propios
protocolos porque empezamos a tomar más
decisiones y no tener miedo jamás se
queden parados muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]